but in Germany police say at least two
shooters are at large and Munich and
police are being urged people rather are
being urged to avoid public spaces as
authorities conduct large-scale
operations The Associated Press reports
that six people are dead many others
wounded at a shopping center public
transportation is halted as police
searched for the suspects the Munich
police are said to be asking residents
to stay indoors earlier reports of a
second shooting have proved to be
unfounded let's get more detail now from
Elisabeth Berman of Bloomberg News she
is in Munich and she joins us now on the
phone Elizabeth what more can you tell
us I think you sounded out pretty well
now I guess what I could add is just a
sense of a city in lockdown and really
all pervasive sense of I'd say fear as
police are still hunting for these
shooters and hasn't yet more new
theories event I mean even from the
office window where I am right now I can
see several police vans police with with
arms patrolling and it's really a sense
of the control of the situation of being
quite under control
Elizabeth given the fact that we just
recently had that attack by that teenage
Afghan immigrant on the train where
passengers were wounded when he was
wielding an axe and a knife can you give
us a sense of how the German authorities
have if at all stepped up their
operations in the wake of that attack
and now what happened today well I think
if you go back a little bit further to
the attack in in need by what was
thought to be somebody acting more or
less by themselves and with little
interaction with terrorist groups like
is I think they would have stepped up
controls and and vigilance even then
with the attack that you're talking
about that happened earlier this week on
the train
following that police found evidence in
the slat of the Afghan refugee that in
fact he had been radicalized by is and
videos as well so I would think that
there
have been very much on a heightened
alert Elizabeth have we heard anything
thus far from Chancellor Angela Merkel
or any of the other High German
officials no we've not we've heard em
some coming from the Bavarian interior
ministry but that was more about
confirming some deaths but there's not
been a response from the federal
government